Newsome here's my suggestion to you  choose a podcast format go for three  hours okay and do it this way you come  to us okay there you go we will  guarantee three hours we'll guarantee  minimum a million dollars to both just  to participate to your campaign we'll do  a super chat people will be able to call  in all that other stuff but it shouldn't  be two minutes I'll stop now okay okay  okay okay okay okay okay no no no no no  no no no I want to see if the Santa I  want to see if Newsom can talk for 10  minutes with an answer and I want to see  if the Santas can give a long answer so  right what do you think about the issues  that we're facing and and let let it be  a different kind of a format you'll get  the money's worth I wouldn't go to CNN I  wouldn't go to Fox I would go to a  pocket